three words
in vitro gametogenesis
perhaps not the most exciting words but
by the end of this video i think you
will agree that they are at least very
interesting and you will also understand
what it means and how it could be useful
for rejuvenating fertility and how it
uses cellular reprogramming to do so
so hello and welcome to the chicky
science show
so in our bodies we have two types of
cells
somatic cells and germ cells
somatic cells are the building blocks of
our bodies whilst germ cells undergo
that process of meiosis which you may
recall from earlier biology studies that
enable the generation of gametes so eggs
for females and sperm for males when
sperm and egg meet an embryo can develop
which inherits the genetic and
epigenetic information from the parents
the egg has an x chromosome if the sperm
does too you get a female two x's and if
the sperm carries a y then you get a
male x y
now i know it's not that straightforward
and there are exceptions but for this
video we'll just roll with it
anyway fertilization between a sperm and
an egg kind of car and bishop bush nine
months later we have a baby
but something important occurs in early
development that is gametogenesis
quite literally generation of gametes so
egg development for females and sperm
for males and so your gem cells begin
developing before you're even born
and originate from so-called primordial
germ cells
they don't quite reach maturity though
and remain in a dormant state until you
guessed it puberty where they further
mature and are ready for fertilization
but what if i told you all this
well as we age our reproductive
potential appears to decline sperm count
declines and spam become less motile
females reach menopause and stop
menstruation
but age is just one factor that comes
into fertility
in fact genetics and lifestyle habits
such as exercise diet drug use and
stress can also influence fertility for
both males and females
and scariest of all was the facts i
learnt whilst reading the book countdown
by dr sharna swan
i sent that by the book title the book
is all about the decline in fertility
counts and to quote from the book it's
also shocking that in some parts of the
world the average 20 something women
today is less fertile than her
grandmother was at 35
and the landmark publication by dr swan
in 2017 showed that sperm counts have
plummeted by 50 in the last 40 years
now in terms of how big a problem this
really is that's really a conversation
of its own but i think it's likely that
either you have personal experience or
know someone who has had fertility
issues
and whilst much research is being
investigated into the causes of these
declines in fertility if these trends
will continue then it could lead to much
suffering to many couples hoping to have
kids
and even more dramatically from the book
for the human race to be able to
reproduce itself
so what can we do about this
well most of you are probably familiar
with current assisted reproductive
technologies such as infantry
fertilization and testosterone
replacement therapy
although the latter may
counterintuitively actually reduce a
man's testosterone levels
but there are limitations with these
techniques they can be expensive and
they don't treat the fundamental
problems necessarily of infertility they
merely assist
that's not to say that they don't work
and they currently are a really great
option for those who are infertile but
can we do any better
well this finally leads me back to in
vitro gametogenesis which hopefully now
as a phrase doesn't look so horrific
basically it is the process of making
gamete cells so extra females spam for
males instead of naturally and vivo in
vitro so in a dish
so to walk you through how this is
achieved let's take a look at this 2020
publication where they generated human
ergonia from induced pluripotent stem
cells and culture so as hinted at by the
title it all begins with human induced
pluripotent stem cells
these induced pluripotent stem cells are
made using a process known as cellular
reprogramming and so you can take a
human differentiated cell like a skin
cell and turn it into a so-called
pluripotent stem cell which has the
potential to replicate
but also to differentiate into different
cell types
so here they introduce the human-induced
pro-potent stem cells into an
intermediate stage called incipient
mesoderm-like cells and from here they
can be turned into human primordial germ
cell-like cells
so if you remember from the start these
are the cells that make gametes so egg
and sperm
and the like is because they are like
the cells but they're not actually the
cells because that would involve taking
them from a human embryo
okay so hopefully you're still with me
we now have some egg cell precursors
and so to get them to turn into oocytes
they have to somewhat simulate what it
would be like in a growing embryo
so the human primordial gem cell-like
cells are then grown with mouse
embryonic ovarian somatic cells which
enables the formation of reconstituted
ovaries
it then takes around four months for the
human cells to differentiate into the
precursory state for oocytes
a similar strategy has also been
developed to do the same thing to make
precursory sperm cells
this process has been so far taken even
further in mouth systems
where they've gone full circle and used
mouse derived precursory egg cells to
make functional embryos and viable
offspring
the pubs were fertile and remained alive
for at least 11 months but they did
notice however that the placentas of the
pups were heavier than a normal mice and
the pups themselves also tended to be
heavier
moreover the success rate of full-time
development was low at 3.5 percent
compared to in fivo generated oversights
at 61.7
so why
well the thing is germ cells undergo
some quite substantial changes early on
in development
one important event is epigenetic
reprogramming
this involves a genome-wide dna
demethylation event which helps to open
up the chromatin making it less
compacted and it erases any imprinting
that is any marks on the dna that would
alter the expression of certain genes
it's honestly a fascinating topic that
we'll just bypass today
and also when females there is so-called
x chromosome reactivation this refers to
the re-expression of genes on the x
chromosome that gets silenced in female
cells to control for gene dosage another
fascinating topic we'll have to leave
for another day
but the intricacies of this process
are not so well defined and have not
been fully recapitulated by performing
gametogenesis in a dish
and so you might say well does that
matter but the reality is
probably yes
epigenetic marks dictate what genes are
expressed and are associated with
optimal embryo development
i'd say this is more of why the
biochemistry anatomy comes out because
unfortunately we still don't fully
understand the mechanism that underlies
the transition
from a human primordial germ cell-like
cell into early oocytes or prosper
matagonia
and in terms of human in
futurigamitogenesis
so far the systems used to generate
oversight or sperm
depends on mouth cells and species
differences may preclude the efficiency
and effectiveness of this process
and so to resolve this you would need to
use human future grenade or somatic
cells but unsurprisingly this isn't
something you can easily order online
due to both technical and ethical issues
you might say well can't we just make
these somatic supporter cells from human
pluripotent stem cells and i would be
like yeah great idea but i don't think
we know how to do that yet but i'm sure
there's probably work being done in the
space
and then the other thing we have to ask
is well is this approach even better
than the current assisted reproductive
technologies
well even if it is never used to treat
fertility
which could change our understanding of
human origins and the continuity of life
it would definitely be a useful tool to
further investigate these early effects
in epigenetic reprogramming and to
better understand the biochemistry of
early development
which i'd have to admit is pretty cool
now this script took me ages to write
and think about
as i am aware that there are indeed
ethical issues and i don't think i have
my own mind made up on it yet
but since the science is out there i
wanted to share with you guys and to
learn from your thoughts too i'm also
aware that here i focused on in feature
comedogenesis and cellular reprogramming
as a solution to the fertility crisis
but this is by far not the only strategy
being investigated and there are many
companies already in or emerging in this
space
so it seems like excellent progress to
me i'm interested in digging deeper into
this technology and i'm aware that there
are also lifestyle changes that could
help those who are infertile as i
learned about from dr shauna swansberg
and so if you're interested in more
videos in this topic then let me know in
the comments otherwise i hope you've
learned something in this video thoughts
i'd let you know that i've now
finally got around to making an official
website that you can go check out if you
want to
thank you to my patreon supporters
and thank you for listening
you